[Music]
on this friday night
new variants and sobering new
predictions
we could see a third wave that is even
worse plus how health officials are
divided on lifting lockdowns
quarantine quarters the rules the
loopholes
and the real cost kids who are covet 19
long haulers my like face is twitching
now
the months-long struggle with lingering
symptoms
and help wanted in space we need new
astronauts
how canadians can apply for an
astronomical opportunity
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us there's a new warning tonight about
the highly contagious variants and fears
they could drive a resurgence of covid19
infections
across this country new modeling shows
there are fewer than 33 000
active cases in canada right now a 60
percent drop compared to a month ago
and deaths are down 58 percent but the
spread of dangerous mutations threatens
to reverse that progress
canada's chief public health officer
says a more stringent approach
is needed current community-based public
health measures will be insufficient to
control rapid growth and resurgence is
forecast
in january at the peak of the pandemic
canada had 8 000 cases a day
now factor in the variance and dr tam
predicts we could have
20 000 cases a day in a third wave
this is a frightening picture as vaccine
distribution finally ramps up
abigail beeman has our top story can
everybody hear me
wait if you can hear me world leaders at
their first virtual g7 meeting
they're just like us can you hear us at
anger
that's okay that's all right you prime
minister justin trudeau attended the
event hosted by the uk
where copenhagen cases have been falling
after grappling with a more
transmissible variant
these variants have been smoldering in
the background and now threatened to
flare up
here's how variant cases have been
climbing in canada
new modeling shows case numbers
hospitalizations and deaths are all
falling across the country
the exceptions newfoundland and labrador
where the spread is blamed on a variant
and nunavut but no variant cases have
been found in any territory so far
the country's top doctor warns if
variants spread and public health
measures are lifted
cases could hit 20 thousand a day next
month
compare that to the latest daily total 3
300
new cases a resurgence is very likely if
people let go of the public health
measures
right now we could see a third wave that
is even
worse than the second or the first
given many provinces are lifting
restrictions as case numbers fall
the premiers and i spoke last night
about not opening up too fast
the prime minister was asked if he told
any of them to slow down on that call
he didn't answer saying it's his job to
support provinces
we need to make sure that even as
provinces look at loosening up
certain restrictions that other
restrictions are kept in and that there
is an ability
to both respond quickly when variants
appear and also an ability to use
rapid tests dr tam said any reopening
needs to be done
carefully and only if sequencing testing
and contact tracing
are all in place robin abigail beeman in
ottawa thanks abigail
the ontario government has extended its
strict stay-at-home orders in three of
the province's coven 19 hot spots
toronto peel region and the north bay
area will be under lockdown for at least
another two weeks
infection rates are high and there are
major concerns over how more
transmissible variants
are circulating in the communities but
as eric sorensen reports there's a real
divide among some health officials
over when to reopen ontario is a case
study in the debate
to open up or not one more region york
is moving from lockdown
to red zone allowing openings with
restrictions for
retail shopping and indoor dining the
region's medical officer of health says
it's the right call
we've been actually seeing a decrease in
the numbers of cases that we have
and our incidence levels are now
compatible with us being in the red zone
but right next door to york a very
different message from health officials
in toronto and peel regions
they want no changes yet worried about
the threat posed by covid variants
by the time the confirmed case counts
are big enough to shock us
it will be too late to do anything so
the premier left
lockdowns in place for three regions
they're on the ground
it's my responsibility to support them
to support our municipal partners
ontario has seen a remarkable drop in
the rate of reported covid cases
from a peak of 167 per 100 000
population
in early january down by more than
two-thirds to 53 last week
compared with the ontario average many
regions have rates lower than that
but toronto and peel still have
significant numbers of covid cases
and variants put a big question mark
over what lies ahead
it's prompted a rare divergence among
public health officials
in york we are fairly confident
that we are not seeing any explosive
behavior
amongst the amongst the variants while
in toronto
the variants of concern mean we face
a deceptively dangerous situation there
are different realities in different
parts of the province absolutely
this epidemiologist says it's a strange
time health officials and politicians
correctly see
things getting better but also possibly
another wave before we're done
we're entering a comfortable zone
because you know the worst of it seems
to be over
but we're also entering a more dire
period where that threat of the third
wave is real
dio nandin and other experts are on
balance becoming more optimistic
there are things that we need to
continue to monitor variance being one
of them we should respect these things
but i think in the big picture we are in
a very good spot
the big picture still some months from
being fully developed
eric sorensen global news toronto
alberta is moving into a new phase of
its vaccine rollout
as of today people living in retirement
centers or other senior supportive
living homes are eligible for the
vaccine
starting on wednesday people over the
age of 75 can receive this shot
as well as first nations and metis age
65 and older
phase two of the vaccine rollout is
expected to begin in april
so far alberta has administered more
than 150
000 doses of the covid19 vaccine
pfizer and his partner biontech have
revealed new data
that shows their vaccine can be safely
stored at standard freeze temperatures
the companies say vials can last in
pharmacies at temperatures between -25
to -15 for two weeks right now the
vaccine requires
ultra cold storage between minus 80 and
minus 60.
the change has been submitted to the u.s
food and drug administration
if approved it could help simplify
distribution of the vaccine
starting on monday all air travelers
returning from non-essential
international trips
will have to isolate in an approved
facility at their own expense
today the federal government released
the list of 11 approved hotels
where travelers will spend their
mandatory three-day quarantine
but as mike trolley explains some
canadians have found legal loopholes
this is our quarantine
quarters monica gibbs isn't looking for
sympathy after a winter with her three
kids in barbados
the caribbean nation offered canadians
the opportunity to live and work
virtually
on an almost coveted free island
and it was paradise until coveted 19
restrictions came into effect in january
so you can only leave for groceries
doctor's appointments or pharmacy
and this weekend is full lockdown so you
actually can't leave your property
she was already thinking of returning
when prime minister justin trudeau
announced on january 29th
all travelers flying into canada would
have to quarantine for up to three days
it was mandatory and trudeau warned it
would be expensive
travelers will then have to wait for up
to three days
at an approved hotel for their test
results
at their own expense which is expected
to be more than two thousand dollars
the rules are strict only travelers who
don't have symptoms can go outside for
limited and monitored outdoor
time i'm comfortable saying that 100 of
my client base
wants nothing to do with this hotel
quarantine that goes into effect
the only way around it is by applying
for compassionate grounds
or by driving over the border call it a
loophole but it's legal
and with no direct flights from barbados
to toronto the gibbs family is flying
into buffalo new york
where they have to take the second of
their three pcr tests
and instead of going back to the airport
for a short flight
they hired a shuttle to drive them home
where they'll quarantine
i don't want to be locked up in a room
with my three kids for three days
that doesn't sound right and remember
that two thousand dollars trudeau
quoted that's not right either because
the government is now saying the hotels
set the rates we called and the average
is around 450
per night for two people not to say
that's not a lot of money but it is not
coming in
at what was the initial comments and put
fear into a lot of people the rules go
into effect on monday
will these hotels be full or will
canadian travelers find a workaround
mike drolie global news toronto the
federal government is extending several
benefit programs to help canadians deal
with the economic fallout of the
pandemic
we're going to increase the number of
weeks of benefits available for the
canada recovery benefit
the canada recovery sickness benefit the
canada recovery caregiving benefit
and employment insurance regular
benefits
the announcement comes as some canadians
were expecting to be cut off next month
the programs will be given extensions
between 12 and 26 weeks
the government says the beefed up
benefits will cost 12.1
billion dollars older adults are still
the most vulnerable to cova 19
but there's growing evidence that the
virus has a significant impact on
children
researchers are finding that initially
mild infections
can have long lasting effects on kids
here's heather yorick's west
alyssa and emily smythe became ill with
covid19
last fall just after their mother a
first responder tested positive
thirteen-year-old emily had only a mild
illness
i had a stuffy nose for 12 hours about
12 hours
and i had a cough for two to three days
but several months later eleven-year-old
alyssa is still
experiencing symptoms my knees are the
worst
but all my joints hurt
and it's mostly when i'm like active
never did we dream that we'd be dealing
with
with symptoms four months later alyssa
is one of a growing number of children
experiencing
long covet a condition first observed
among adult patients where symptoms
persist
months after an initial covit 19
infection
is resolved it's known in adults that
many people have long-haul symptoms
weren't hospitalized so it's not that
it's associated with more severe disease
mild initial infections have also been
connected to the covet-linked
multi-system inflammatory syndrome
also known as miss c we kept telling her
you can do
it you can do this and then at one point
she said
mommy i can't do this in the u.s cases
of miss see
are rising in arizona 12-year-old
elizabeth english died in early december
the condition which emerges several
weeks after an initial covet infection
is still considered rare but canadian
doctors say they're seeing cases here
more and more we've had over 130
patients now that we've cared for
at sickkids with miss c during both the
first and second wave
this wave the kids have needed a little
bit more intensive care
treatment it's why dr ray young says
it's so important
that research continues so that vaccines
can be approved for use in children soon
as well
covet 19 may not be as deadly for
children but there is growing evidence
that the virus
can have long lasting impacts heather
urex west global news calgary
canada's defense minister gets grilled
coming up the tough questions for
harjeet sudjan about the country's
former top soldier
and beam back from mars new pictures of
the red planet
a house of commons committee is looking
into the allegations against canada's
former top soldier
general jonathan vance is accused of
inappropriate behavior with two female
subordinates
several top officials including defense
minister harjeet sudjan
were asked about what they knew and why
there was no investigation
our ottoman bureau chief mercedes
stephenson broke this story
and has been following the hearings
mercedes what did the defense minister
have to say today
well robin there were more questions
than answers by the defense minister at
the committee
he wouldn't answer questions from
members of parliament that included
basic information
like what he knew when he knew it or who
the minister
told it to as global news has reported
the military ombudsman approached the
minister in 2018 to raise concerns
about general vance's behavior around
women
we've heard from sources who say that
sagin's office emailed the privy council
office to let them know about it
but we haven't been able to find out who
knew more whether the prime minister was
informed which
he's refused to answer or what exactly
the defense minister told him
you could see the frustration from mps
at committee today who pressed the
minister on whether
it is him and his actions that are under
investigation or general vances
that's because as you'll see in this
clip the minister continually refers
back to the military police
investigation going on now
as the reason why he can't answer
questions about what he did
i'm asking for you to confirm to me
whether you knew or did not know about
these allegations
before they became public and i'm sure i
have i want to make it very
very clear here i'm not implying
anything what i'm saying here is that
the conf the uh the conversations and
the meetings are
confidential when it comes to uh the
ombudsman's office
but what i'm saying here is that any
allegation there were any
brought forward who are always taken to
the appropriate authorities no one's
asking about the investigation we're
asking about your actions
as the minister bureaucrats from the
privy council office
also appeared they were the office
notified by minister sagin's office
about allegations they said they didn't
have enough
information to actually act raising the
question mark of still
why more wasn't done we'll have more on
the west block
this weekend that will further develop
this story
tune in robin mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks mercedes
fire and ice still ahead how fire crews
battled a blaze in texas with hydrants
frozen solid
you're watching global national
as you mentioned
the fire chief didn't get a chance to
explain that crews had to truck in
water to fight a fire at an apartment
building in san antonio texas
the deep freeze gripping the state has
frozen fire hydrants
the flames took over the building
thursday afternoon raging for more than
14 hours
all 50 residents were taken to a nearby
evacuation center
no one was hurt
the power is slowly coming back in texas
but not the taps
millions of people who endured rolling
blackouts are now under
boil water advisories they're also
relying on emergency rations after
finding long lines and bare shelves at
supermarkets
two back-to-back storms are being blamed
for the deaths of at least 58 people
across the united states there's growing
concern last week's earthquake may have
caused more damage to japan's fukushima
nuclear plant than initially thought
water used to keep the plant cool has
fallen in two reactors
that indicates there's a leak but it's
confined to the buildings
the new damage could further complicate
the plant's already difficult
decommissioning process
which is expected to take decades in
2011
a powerful magnitude 9.1 earthquake and
tsunami
damaged the plant's cooling systems
causing a nuclear meltdown
a warning this next story is hard to
watch dozens of short finned
pilot whales have died in indonesia
despite a desperate rescue mission to
save the pod
the whales somehow stranded themselves
on a beach on the island of madura
volunteers tried to push the mammals
back out to sea but only three of the 46
whales could be saved
witnesses say some cavs returned to the
beach hoping to find their mothers
and the young wills couldn't be saved
it's not fully understood why whales
beach themselves but they are known to
be highly social and travel
in large groups astronaut ambitions
up next a space agency is hiring and
canadians can apply
prince philip has spent a third night in
a london hospital
there are reports he will stay there
until early next week
at an abundance of caution the 99 year
old was feeling
unwell and admitted to hospital tuesday
prince harry and his wife megan have
made their final formal split from the
royal family
a statement by buckingham palace says
while we are all saddened by their
decision
the duke and duchess of sussex remain
much-loved members of the family
the pair has stepped away from full-time
royal life last march and won't be
returning to royal duties
harry will also lose his honorary
military titles
we're getting a sneak peek from mars
tonight nasa's perseverance rover has
sent some incredible images back to
earth
this image captured moments before
perseverance touched down
shows dust plumes created by the rover's
engines
and you can really pick up the color of
the red planet in this high resolution
image
it's a revolutionary time for space
exploration an
era that is inspiring the european space
agency to expand its roster
today it put a call out for new
astronauts the agency says the ideal
candidate should have a master's degree
in sciences or mathematics
b between the ages of 27 and 37 and the
best part
canadians can apply as crystal gamansing
reports the job will expand
their horizons
astronaut is a top career pick for kids
but the dream of suiting up doesn't have
to fade with age
it's an amazing journey i think it will
be an opportunity to learn a lot about
yourselves
your strengths your weaknesses it's the
first european space
agency recruitment drive in 11 years
the process for candidates will be
arduous
including six stages of tests to
challenge scientific
technical and mental fortitude we have
astronauts from the last selection and
they are still active astronauts and
i would like to see them again going
into orbit going into space
but at the same time we need also new
astronauts to secure
a continuity three two
one with private companies such as
spacex the prospects have
increased for more human missions
spacing and chris hadfield re-energized
the image of an
astronaut
[Music]
it's not just the next major tom but
major
tammy that the esa is looking for the
agency
strongly encourages women to apply
we expect and we hope that thousands of
people will apply
the chances of success are slim
but i think it's a great opportunity
canada has a cooperation agreement with
the agency and the recruitment process
is open to those from member
and associate states to be part of this
international
team that can actually make a real
difference it's a real privilege and
it's it's it was that really that
motivated me to want to be part of this
team
a team doing a job where the
possibilities
are literally out of this world crystal
gomencing global news
london and that is global national for
this friday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
this snow reptile in beaconsfield quebec
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you